we're in a bit of a predic event the man  was killed please take the wind  we need to clear our names oh that's  something  it was killed because of something that  he had seen because of an organization  we want to rule the world  rule the world  we need you good people to help us out  it's the only hope that we have to get  out of this situation let's hope this  goes well  things have got more complicated  okay you want to start this  drink's on me  literally  [Music]  where this came  was going to have today  Amsterdam rated R did someone slap you  Bert because you have a red mark on your  face I got Schwab I got punched oh no no  theaters October 7th